بينما لا يزال الوضع
متوترًا للغاية على الحدود بين بولندا
وبيلاروسيا ، انظر إلى الجانب القطبي يقول
إنه سيظل صعبًا ولن يسمح
للمهاجرين الذين يقيمون في
المعسكر على الجانب
البيلاروسي بالمرور والدخول إلى أراضي الاتحاد الأوروبي
الآن أصبح لدى صناديق الاقتراع الآن
حوالي 15000 جندي وعناصر حدودي
هنا في المنطقة الحدودية ، لقد وضعوا أيضًا
منطقة حظر نحن
نقف على حافة منطقة الحظر هذه في
الوقت الحالي ، ولا
يُسمح للصحفيين بالدخول و  لا يُسمح للمنظمات غير الحكومية
بالدخول ، أما الآن
فتقول استطلاعات الرأي إنه كانت هناك
أكثر من مائة محاولة لمحاولة عبور
الأراضي البولندية من
الجانب البيلاروسي من قبل المهاجرين ، لكنهم
يقولون إنهم تمكنوا حتى الآن من
إحباط الجميع  من المحاولات التي
تمت الآن كانت هناك حادثة واحدة
محددة حدثت في صباح يوم الجمعة
عندما تقول الاستطلاعات أن مجموعة أكبر
تمكنت من الوصول إلى
أراضي بيلا الروسية  نشروا بعض مقاطع
الفيديو لهم حول حدوث ذلك ، لكنهم
يقولون إنهم تمكنوا من
السيطرة على هذا الوضع واحتجاز
الأشخاص الذين نجحوا في عبور الحدود
، كما تقول مراكز الاقتراع
إنهم مستهدفون من قبل قوات الأمن الروسية
التي تستخدم بيلا.  مؤشرات الليزر في
بعض الحالات الآن ينكر الروس البيلا
من جانبهم معظم
المزاعم الموجهة ضدهم
ويتهمون أيضًا استطلاعات الرأي بكونها
قاسية جدًا في الطريقة التي يتعاملون بها
مع الموقف أي عدم
السماح للمهاجرين بالمرور.  تشهد استطلاعات الرأي
الكثير من الدعم الدولي
خاصة من حلفائهم من
الاتحاد الأوروبي ، ولكن أيضًا على سبيل
المثال نائبة الرئيس الأمريكي كامالا هاريس
أعربت أيضًا عن دعمها لبولندا
وأيضًا انتقدت بالطبع بيلا الروسي
القوي ألكسندر لوكاشينكو ناتو
معربًا أيضًا عن قلقه بشأن الوضع  هنا
عند هذه الحدود ونقول أيضًا إنها
تقف بقوة وراء البولنديين
والاتحاد الأوروبي  يبدو أن es قد
حققت انتصارًا طفيفًا على الأقل في
كل هذا مع إعلان
الناقلة الرئيسية البيلاروسية بيل آفيا أنها
لن تسمح للقادمين من العراق
وسوريا واليمن أيضًا بركوب طائراتها
للحضور إلى مينسك بالطبع أحد
الأشياء  الذي يقوله الاتحاد الأوروبي هو
أنهم يؤمنون أساسًا بأن
ألكسندر لوكاشينكو
الرجل القوي الروسي يستدرج الناس خاصة
من تلك البلدان إلى بيلاروسيا
لمحاولة إرسالهم عبر الحدود fred
platkin cnn cujnitsa poland